for more than 35 years he's lit up the
pages of 2008 alongside characters such
as Judge Dredd and strontium dog
capturing the imagination of comic-book
fans across the globe he's the star of
the recently announced rogue trooper
Redux a brand new remaster of our 2006
BAFTA nominated tactical shooter but
loved by fans for its thrilling
authentic adaptation the rogue trooper
comic but you may be asking yourself who
is rogue trooper or more importantly
what is rogue trooper the rogue trooper
or rogue for short is a GI a genetic
infantryman biologically engineered to
survive the poisonous atmosphere of new
earth where all-out war rages he's a
one-man Squad he carries with him the
consciousnesses of three fallen G is
stored as bio chips and implanted into
his equipment with them supporting his
already advanced abilities he's a force
like no other he's a renegade last
survivor of the cortizone massacre that
wiped out the GIS he now only has one
mission to avenge his fallen comrades he
is the ultimate soldier engineered for
war driven by revenge he is the rogue
trooper we're not quite ready to show
you roping Redux in all these remastered
glory yet but we can show you the
brand-new rogue who will feature in the
game
be made from the ground up with
current-gen the quality materials and
higher resolution geometry on with a new
look
that brings in backers classics liquor
style from the original comics rogue has
never looked better
thanks for watching we'll have more of
road trip of redox to show you very soon
- stay tuned
[Music]